right now there's a very special
mosquito flying around a laboratory in
California it's carrying a genetic
weapon one that might be capable of
wiping out one of the world's most
deadly diseases malaria which kills half
a million people every year all that
suffering might end if we just open the
window and let this creature out but
will we do it the mosquito is just one
project of thousands for a new gene
editing tool called CRISPR that's
absolutely transforming biological
science it's only four years old but in
preliminary lab experiments it's already
been used to eliminate HIV reverse
mutations that cause blindness and stop
cancer it could even one day be used to
reverse human aging more than a billion
dollars has been invested and this
really is just the beginning CRISPR
works like a pair of DNA scissors
geneticists program a piece of RNA much
like they would write a bit of software
code and that guides the scissors to a
very specific location on the genome
snip snip and out goes any unwanted
genes and in goes the good stuff the
breaks in the double helix heal
automatically this is true cut and paste
genetics and it's making the science
fiction of a decade ago seem completely
plausible today CRISPR shortens genetic
engineering work from years to weeks and
reduces the cost of each experiment from
more than $5,000 before CRISPR to less
than $50 now a person with a background
at genetics can learn the basics in a
day or two the genome is now a dry erase
board that anyone can scribble on
consider our mosquito scientists have
successfully used CRISPR to deliver a
genetic tweak that makes mosquitoes
immune to the malaria parasite so they
can't spread it to humans but there was
still a problem how to get this gene to
spread through an entire population of
mosquitoes genetic changes are usually
only inherited by half an organisms
offspring and by a quarter of those
offsprings offspring it's quickly
swallowed up by a large gene pool but
last year scientists unveiled another
CRISPR breakthrough a gene drive that
pushes the genetic changes to almost a
hundred percent of office
mosquitos reproduced so quickly immunity
could flash through an entire population
of mosquitoes in a single season boon no
more malaria the gene drive isn't
perfect yet but it's getting there and
the biggest question holding the
mosquito back is no longer about the
science of what's possible but of what's
advisable are we really ready to take
over the blueprints of life on Earth
there isn't much time for debate soon
some of the first human trials we use
CRISPR based therapies to treat genetic
diseases a farm in North Carolina is
preparing to raise CRISPR pigs in order
to transplant their organs into humans
or Dow DuPont is already field testing
new versions of wheat and corn and by
2020 you can bet that all sorts of
subtly different fruits vegetables and
even meats will start showing up in your
grocery store CRISPR is the key to
unlocking bioengineering for better and
maybe for worse an international summit
of scientists met in Washington in
December to agree on some basic limits
to ethical CRISPR research regarding
human embryos they decided that research
should continue but that the human
genome shouldn't be altered in ways that
can be passed to future generations at
least not yet
right now the CRISPR field is fraught
with some pretty freaky science and
ethical conundrums and the human species
truly must tread carefully but with the
promise that CRISPR offers we may come
to a point where it's unethical to keep
the window closed on some of this
technology and that time may be coming
sooner than you think
you